this has never been done before
ever
keeping a diary has fundamentally
changed my life it's the single thing
that has advanced my personal
development more than anything else that
I've done I always say there's no
personal development without
self-awareness you can read as many
books as you like but if you can't read
yourself you'll never learn a thing this
is the world's first Diary that listens
to you understands you and then provides
you with tailored support from the
world's leading experts in health
Finance work and relationships so that
you can overcome the things that are
limiting you in order to reach your
Highest Potential a limited number of
these Diaries are going to go on sale in
November and the waiting list is open
now so go to
thediary.com and add your name if you
want to come on this journey with me
it's a mental game and when you see your
counterpart smashing up headphones and
Landing accounts you know that you've
got this Christian Horner the team boss
of the world championship winning team
Red Bull Racing
you came into Red Bull when it was isn't
doing great when I came into the sport I
was the youngest team principal in
Formula One I still am to this day
ironically and I don't have any formal
qualifications for a couple of a levels
I wanted to make sure that we were the
team on the upward graft and think okay
how can we turn [ __ ] into fertilizer you
can lose championships as we've seen
yeah in seconds
it felt like it was slipping away and
then suddenly it was insane if somebody
came up with the script and said that's
the way this season's going to pan out
nobody would have believed it all that
press scrutiny
Formula One is a very glamorous World
from the outside looking in it can be a
lonely place at times have you ever had
moments of anxiety yeah it sort of crept
up on me without
you know recognizing it and this is just
your body telling you that
there's a lot going on here and uh for
me you know I've had enough
when you look at your competition which
has been Mercedes yes why do you think
your team will win
I think that
before this episode begins I just want
to say a huge thank you to all of our
new subscribers 74 of you that watch
this channel didn't subscribe before and
we're now down to about 71 so that helps
us in a number of ways that are quite
hard to explain but simply the bigger
the channel gets the bigger the guests
get so if you haven't yet subscribed to
the Diary of a CEO if I can have any
favors from you if you've ever watched
the show and enjoyed it it's just to
please hit the Subscribe button without
further Ado I'm Stephen Butler and this
is the Diary of a CEO I hope nobody's
listening but if you are then please
keep this yourself
[Music]
Christian
[Music]
there's a slight pun I guess to this
opening question but um as I look back
into your early years and as you look
back in hindsight and sort of
self-assess
what drives you
what drives me I'm naturally a
competitive person and uh you know I've
always you know enjoyed competition I've
always enjoyed working you know within a
team of people and uh and winning you
know winning there's just no no feeling
like it in uh you know whether it's
achieving a checkered flag first or
sealing a deal to get on a car
um you know that's always what's what's
Driven me has always been about the
competition
in our earliest years I think you know
this psychology shows that we're we're
formed most definitively by the things
that happen the context we're growing up
in older brothers you know the parenting
when you look back and connect those
dots is there anything else there that
um is important context to who you are
today
well I'm the middle child of of three so
my older brother was was the the
sensible one of of the three of the
three boys
um and then my younger brother was more
outrageous I would say and and the
middle child is always that slightly
awkward one
um yes particularly within within three
so
um yeah I wasn't I didn't excel at
school I wasn't that interested in
school school for me was almost like a a
social thing but I enjoyed Sport and I
enjoyed team sport at school so where my
older brother was quite academic he was
he was crap at sport
um whereas you know I played in the
football team or the cricket team or or
whatever was whatever was going and um
you know I I just enjoyed that and uh I
think that you know being a being a
middle child
um yeah you're always slightly different
the the younger ones always ends up
being the spoiled one the older one's a
sensible one and the the middle one
tends to be in his own lane for
certainly from the the middle children
that I've met what did you think you
were going to be when you grew up I
wanted to be Evil Knievel well you know
I wanted to be a stunt man
um and then there was a program
um full guy with Lee Majors in it who
drove around in a big truck and
and so on like it was a stuntman and I
thought that was super cool so I was
always a fascinated by cars and speed
and and so on so that attracted me to
um you know just just
world of of engines and from a very
early age from about 12 yeah I was
pestering and pestering my mum because I
knew my father wouldn't uh wouldn't buy
me want to get to buy a a motorized
go-kart and I saved out what I had and
then for my 12th birthday
um we found this thing in the back of a
uh a newspaper this second hand uh sort
of 20 year old go-kart and it was too
low to drive around a farm on the grass
so we found a track and suddenly I
discovered this you could race these
things and and suddenly that wetted my
appetite at a very young age
um and yeah Nigel Mansell at the time
was a complete hero of mine I was
starting to get into into Formula One so
from a very early age you know I became
almost obsessive about wanting to be a a
racing driver to the point that I didn't
want to grow any taller I got you know
to
five foot seven and thought yeah I don't
want to go any any thought I was almost
willing myself to
um to be sure
so uh uh because all racist drivers
tended to be sort of pint-sized during
that that that time so for me that was
my dream I could just visualize myself
being a being a racing driver and that's
you know everything else became
secondary at that point
what influence did your mother and
father have separately on you
they had they had a huge influence on me
both in in in in different ways my
father worked in the automotive industry
so he shared a passion for for cars and
engines and and
um Motor Racing you know he was uh he'd
done some marshalling in his Youth and
always liked being around around cars he
always had you know nice cars and and
working in that industry
um yeah he was hugely hugely
knowledgeable and my mother you know my
mother was would always encourage us to
follow our dreams and she'd always push
us as as children like never to accept
you know just
being
uh you know run-of-the-mill always push
yourself always extend yourself
um and so she had an awful lot of drive
you know in her and so it was a
combination you know of the of the two
so once I discovered this world of of
motor racing so around the age of age of
12 you know my father and I were able to
then you know we spent quite a lot of
time together you know traveling the
country and then racing internationally
and then into car racing and so on and
it was a it was a great thing to be able
to you know to share with him and he you
know he made a lot of sacrifices to help
meet him in my career
um my brothers both had the chance to to
have a go at racing neither of them were
were you know were interested
um and so we spend a lot of time going
up and down the country the different
cart races my mama pack a you know pack
all the sandwiches up and you know it
became a family thing
um going to these different racing
events
I'm really intrigued by that winning
streaking people and that
competitiveness because not everybody
and you would have seen this in the
drivers and the people you've worked
with not everybody has that they don't
have that like competitive tenacity
where they just they just have to win
yeah where does where does that come
from in you have you figured that out is
it something which has built over time
was there always a bit of a glimmer of
that winning at all costs or I think
it's something that's in in your DNA and
look I've got I'm one of three uh boys
and I in our family and I'm very
different to my to my brothers and um
you know I've got the same parents
um but we're all very different and I
think you either have it
you know or you or you don't and uh you
know I I always had this inner drive and
and desire
um there was purely focused around you
know moderation I didn't visit envisage
myself being a tennis player or you know
and anything else I just wanted to to to
race I just wanted to compete and I
would watch hours and hours of video
footage on VHS tapes of old races and
Grand Prix and you know study the
minutest of details of you know what
racing boots Nigel Mansfield was wearing
or or you know you you totally engross
yourself in all aspects of it and uh and
I think visualization is a big thing as
well so I think if you've if you
visualize something and you really want
it I've found in certainly in my life
that you know that's that's absolutely
achievable because you said you're
selling yourself a Target you're setting
yourself a goal and and that's what
you've got to shoot for
I've talked about around visualization I
think there was a book that came out
called the secret which um
somewhat painted visualization as a
uh Supernatural force in the world that
kind of conspires to give you what you
want when you talk about visualization
do you see it as a supernatural force or
do you see it as much more of a
practical satellite navigation of I
think
I think you could see it as both in many
respects uh uh you know I'm
probably more practical in my in my
thinking so I'm not engaged with the
supernatural uh but but yeah I'm a great
believer that if you visualize something
if you see yourself
being on that Podium and you believe in
it and you want it and you really strive
for you you can you can achieve it and I
didn't achieve it as a driver but I went
on to achieve it as a uh you know as a
team principal and um
uh yeah and whether that's winning a
Grand Prix or winning a world
championship
um winning uh Constructors World
Championship it's it's having that
belief having never losing sight of that
that goal because that's what takes you
through the
the you know the tough days the
difficult days
um when everything seems to be
conspiring against you that you've got
to keep believing in that Target and
visualizing that that Target
um and I would say by and large during
my career that's that's that's come true
you talked about your kind of obsessive
focus on the details even looking at a
very young age looking at these
cassettes and seeing what boots they
were wearing
that Obsession as well that that
Obsession on the smallest of details how
is that played a role in everything that
happened throughout the the next couple
of Decades of your life I think it's
it's just a question of living no stone
unturned just always pursuing all the
incremental areas because they all they
all add up and it's all about attention
to details and sometimes it's the
smallest things that can make the
largest of difference and you you
collectively add all of those elements
together
um and they add up at the end of the day
so
um you know particularly in the business
that I'm operating in in Formula One it
is all about the detail it is all about
leaving no stone unturned about pushing
the boundaries about it's extracting
every ounce of performance out of these
amazing machines which ultimately
um it's the people that drive that and
so it's so for creating a culture
that empowers that that
um uh that essence of of it never being
enough always striving to achieve more
and uh and then it's almost the fear of
failure that uh that drives you on
because once you've sampled and you've
tasted success it becomes addictive like
a drug and and you just want to
experience it again and you have that
have that winning feeling
it's interesting so let's start with the
culture piece then with the team so you
said it's about creating that culture a
culture where every detail matters in a
practical way there'll be loads of
people listening to this podcast now
that are building projects or businesses
or they might have a dance class
whatever they're doing
um
how do they practically
make those around them really appreciate
the small stuff I think you have to lead
by example and I think that uh you know
it's all about
um uh you you know just continually
looking to to improve to be better so
for example the races that we win you
know you can always learn it's never
ever enough
um you know the last race we won in in
Monza could we have done a better job on
the strategy could we have been quicker
in the pit stop
um could we have had a better start was
our preparation in the lead up to the
race you know good enough did we focus
enough attention in the practice
sessions on the things that that turned
out to be important in the Grand Prix so
being self-analytical and is is a key
aspect of driving of driving performance
and never being satisfied saying yep
that was good enough because it never is
there's always something that you can
learn that you can uh that you can
improve and that you you can build on as
you're building this database of
continual knowledge
does that change how you choose people
to join the team are you looking for
people that have a predisposition to
care about the small stuff or that have
are detail-orientated I think you need
uh you know within a team you need
different strengths for different roles
and so when within formula one you've
got obviously the design side of the of
the business the creative side of the
business you've got the operational side
where you've got to manufacturer these
these incredible cars and then operate
them cost effectively at 22 Grand Prix
around around the globe and so you need
different people for different roles but
it's all having that commonality of
which is the car which is you know these
two amazing machines that we have to
turn out at these 22 races a year and to
operate at their at their Optimum and
that is the focal point you know that
everybody's uh you know vested interest
is is involved in so you've got to have
uh you know a collective mix of people
that that create a team but as long as
the goal that everybody is reaching for
and striving for is the same
you know you're gonna have a a myriad of
different personalities I mean we're
we're circus sort of seven to eight
hundred people uh you know in our team
plus then on top of that we've got an
engine group that we're we're building
as well so over a thousand people on one
campus in Milton Keynes and uh of course
you're going to get a vast range of of
personalities and characters but the one
thing is common is it's all about the
car it's all about performing on the
track how does one keep is that 22
different departments as well yeah so
it's a 22 different departments across
across the business and it for me
um it's about getting the right people
in the right roles and empowering them
to do their job so that they've got
clear you know objectives clear targets
that they've that they're you know
they're shooting for and then backing
them so I see a lot of my role is to
ensure that they've got the support
around them they've got the tools around
them that uh that they're defending when
they need defending
and that they're guided when they need
that with that when they need guidance
and I think that there's no point I'm
not neurodynamicist or an engine
engineer or I don't have any formal you
know qualifications bar a couple of a
levels
um so I'm not a specialist in any any
one area so my role is to ensure that
I'm putting the right people in the
right roles and getting them
collectively to work together
I feel like that is the that is the
ultimate goal of business it's funny
because as as entrepreneurs sometimes we
think that we should be good at
everything or that we should um we
should know how to do every job better
than the person you know within within
that team but what you said there I
think is was very much very very true in
the sense of it's finding the right
people and binding them with a culture
that gets the best out of them which is
not an easy thing to do it's not because
you know there's a lot of Pride people
have egos as as well but I think it's
accepting where your strengths and where
your weaknesses are and I think that
that not everybody can be a phenomenal
aerodynamicist or a you know engine
engineer or a chassis designer or uh you
know a number one mechanic
um and it's a matter of identifying you
know the right people for the right
roles and then and empowering them to
get on their job there's no point me
employing Adrian Nui as you know
probably the best there was announced in
the in the history of the sport and then
telling him you know how to do his job
or telling Max for staff on how to how
to drive a car you know you can point
out things that you're seeing
um and and you can uh you know offer
some some guidance but in terms of it's
down to them in their specialist areas
to you know to to operate and you try
and give them the right tools in the
right environment
that enables them to flourish and
succeed have you had a instances in your
career where you've hired a very
talented [ __ ] and what I mean by that
is someone who's so good at their job
but ego personality something has just
well Formula One attracts them and um
and uh Egos and [ __ ] are not too far
apart sometimes
um so but you know you there's no I in
team and I think that you quickly you
see
um if you have a talented individual
that isn't working in a team environment
they quickly become isolated
um and they either change their way and
and embrace the team
or they end up Falling by the wayside
and not achieving their you know their
potential because
it's too big a sport to be
um you know an individualist in in it
you need to rely and Trust in the other
people around you in the other
departments are around you to be able to
fulfill your your part
much of much of management
um I think starts with knowing how to
manage yourself
because if you if you don't manage
yourself successfully then you can be a
pretty awful manager yeah
how how you talked about the
self-analysis self-analyzing the team
after races but do you self-analyze
yourself
yeah of course I mean you're always
thinking you know what
what can I do better you know how could
I how could I perform better as a CEO or
as a team principal
um did I handle that situation correctly
could you know is there
another way that we could have addressed
that and I think that what I've learned
over time is that I used to you know
when I first came into the sport
I'd worry about
almost everything
and I quickly came to the conclusion
well there's no point in worrying about
everything worry about the things you
can control the things that you can't
control
don't let them take your energy don't
let them take your you know your your
focus or distract you focus on the
things that that you're empowered that
to make a difference in
um and then I just I I'm able to I was
able to become more disciplined with my
time in implying my time more uh more
effectively than being spread too thin
emotional control in sports it's very
passionate yeah there's a fine line
isn't it from what I've observed with
some of the great you know managers in
the world like Sir Alex Ferguson and
football stars and between like the
passion and letting the passion get out
of hand yeah absolutely anger and you
know how do you balance that and is it a
balancing act well I think
I think the Brits are quite good at that
you know they're keeping a stiff upper
lip and you know head down and get on
with it and for me
you know last year's World Championship
was very much about that and um you
could see I mean it was a Titanic battle
not just between the two drivers on
track but by you know the two teams off
track and the person you're gauging
yourself uh and you're pitched against
as a team principal is is your opposite
number
and it's a mental game as much as a
physical uh activity as well and of
course it was the first time that that
team in the
seven eight year period had come under
under any form of pressure and I think
you see people's true personalities and
what they've really got when they're
under pressure so of course
you know when you see your counterpart
smashing up headphones and pointing and
ranting at cameras you know that you've
got to them because then you know that
if they're venting in such a way and
they're feeling that pressure that the
people beneath them
are going to be offloaded onto as well
that they're going to be on the
receiving end of that and that in my
opinion or my experience it caused
people to tighten up
um and I remember Before the Race in Abu
Dhabi getting all the guys together
and say look whatever happens today is
going to happen
um you know all we can do is do the best
that we can do today and the most
important thing is you know be proud of
what you've achieved to get us to this
position that we're fighting for this
world championship you know that we've
taken it all the way down to the wire
and most of all enjoy it
you know enjoy this experience whatever
whatever the outcome is going to be we
don't know but just let's go in there
with an approach of give it everything
and enjoy it and embrace it and in the
end you know it paid off and I think
that as a leader how you conduct
yourself
permeates throughout a business so if if
you're feeling the tension and you're
passing that on
then for me that's not a healthy
way to lead a team by fear you want it
to be inclusive you want it to be open
you want people to be able to feel that
they can
that they've got a voice and that voice
will be you know will be heard rather
than being afraid to speak up for fear
of getting there you know they had taken
off
I came into Red Bull when
um it wasn't doing great as a team and
over the the next five six six years you
really turned that ship around
from the outside I mean people might see
that as quite a simple thing but I was
reading about how you
um
you'd come to work on your first day of
work the Consultants had flown over and
fired the previous management team which
is always causes a little bit of unease
shall I say and then they fly out and
leave you there and then from there
you've got 450 people in this team
that's kind of dysfunctional it's not
it's not reaching its potential
tell me because there's a lot of I
always think about going into companies
where there's an existing culture and
how you unpick it and turn it around
tell me how you did that at Red Bull
well that first day I arrived I remember
um arriving in uh in the office with a a
secretary that was in tears because her
previous boss had been Justified
um there was unopened Christmas cards on
the day so half cup of coffee uh okay
and a fairly disgruntled Workforce that
had been through a revolving door of
management changes whilst the team had
been uh you know owned by Jaguar so um
it's like okay how am I you know what's
my game plan here and my my plan was
engage with the people understand
what are the issues listen you spend you
know the next few months just listening
and form your own picture and so
you know that's what I did over the
first couple of months I spent time
walking around the factory engaging with
people listening and then the picture
started to come clear that you know
there were Pockets within the team that
that you know there was real capability
and and talent but it was just clear
that they weren't
working collectively there was this
blame culture within the business where
the drawing office blamed Arrow Arrow
blamed at the wind tunnel
um you know r d playing production the
race team were blamed everybody
um and it was just this blame culture
that there was no accountability or
Collective you know responsibility so it
was then a question of okay how do we
unpick that and how do we create the
glue to bring this this together and for
me
what was really needed was was technical
Direction
um and I thought well look I'm going to
go after the best in the business
um and that was Adrian newey Adrian had
had an incredible career at Williams and
McLaren
um and you know they've been you know a
couple of years where McLaren hadn't
been delivering at its uh at its
potential and you could see that
business was changing and it just felt
like there was a window of opportunity
so
uh you know I'm made sure I got to
uh to meet Adrian and I built up a
relationship with him and uh his then
wife and then managed to convince him to
come and join the team
um and that was a litmus moment because
then suddenly people woke up and say wow
if Adrian knew is prepared to come here
he must see something that he he
believes in
um and uh you know we set off set off
from there and that then you know you
know Galvanize a technical group because
Adrian's the most single-minded you know
engineer I've ever uh ever come across
um and you know that that
Galvanize the team because it was well
if Adrian says that's the direction
we're going technically that's that's
the way we're going and um it then put a
sense of purpose into the design office
and that enabled me to attract more
talent to supplement what was there to
weed out the few bits that needed
tidying up but the core basis of the
team
hadn't really changed from what had been
under achieving at Jaguar we just put in
clear leadership into a into a structure
and started to instill a culture of it's
not just about having the seventh
biggest budget which means you're going
to finish seventh is a question of okay
what can we do how can we push the
boundaries how can we be more in as
Innovative how can we
take the fight
to the guys at the front because we're
not prepared to settle you know being
seventh we want to win how how what is
the fastest route
to getting uh into a winning position
okay so I've got three questions there
that came to mind
the first one was about
single-mindedness
in in business and in leadership
sometimes single-mindedness is seen as
being undemocratic and like I think
there's sometimes people think that
organizations are supposed to be like
Democratic where everyone gets a vote
and then we decide which direction we're
going in based on the vote
but you've highlighted single-mindedness
in that instance as being a real unifier
and a real motivator yeah absolutely and
look you know obviously you want to
listen and you want to gauge but the end
of the day somebody's got to make a
decision sometimes that might not be the
most popular of decisions but the most
important thing is to make a decision to
say this is the direction that we're
going in and the most important thing
with that once you've committed to a
decision to make sure that you give it
your best shot but if it's not working
to recognize that it's not working and
not be afraid to change to stick your
hands okay we got it wrong let's let's
go another route because that the worst
thing is just repeating the same mistake
after mistake you know after mistake and
I think you know good leadership
um is strong leadership where
you know people want to know what is the
direction what is the objective why are
we doing this
um what are we pushing for what are we
striving for
um and uh you know it's about taking
people on that on that Journey but uh
about having you know very clear goals
and objectives that that taking them on
the journey with you
I guess that's a job of inspiration and
communication
how how important is that when you're
trying to get 450 people to come along
with you really making sure you've
nailed down communication and I guess
inspiring communication and how has Red
Bull done that I think Red Bull
um you know as a business is a
phenomenal business that have uh you
know it's a Maverick brand it's it's
pushed the boundaries in everything that
it does it's
it's a lifestyle band it's um it's
always been edgy you know with the
extreme sports that they've been
involved in and and so I'm a bit of a
you know very much a Maverick and I
think taking that DNA and
you know implementing it within a
Formula One team has been you know
incredibly effective and uh what's
enabled us to be dynamic is that we've
had the full support you know of the of
the chairman you know of Dietrich
matoshits who has been passionate about
this uh this activity
and he's you know unwaveringly you know
backed us and there were difficult days
where
you know things can't you know what came
under scrutiny but he gave the time
um and the stability within and allowed
the stability within the business for us
to really
cultivate you know a winning machine and
with the key people in the right in in
the right positions and uh uh you know
he's been phenomenal in the support that
he's shown us and the and the freedom
that he's enabled us to have to operate
effectively efficiently quickly and
sharply without being bogged down by the
process of a uh you know a corporate
entity
um so we've kept that agility
and even though the company has grown to
three times the size that uh when when
Rebel came into the sport is maintain
that racing spirit that that ability to
make quick decisions whether it's on a
driver or a sponsor or a a member of
Staff or us you know whatever it may be
we've had that Dynamic ability to move
and adapt quickly
so important I spend so long you know I
spent 10 years working with CEOs and
Founders on their marketing and what I'd
see time and time again how really the
cost wasn't being wrong it was being
slow so it was taking nine months to
find out you were wrong versus the team
over here that would spend so if we were
pitching an idea we pitch it to two
companies at the same time say one of
them would take nine months to find out
that the idea was bad the other one
would take one week to find out it was
bad and they'd be open to the next one
and that and people don't think of like
the design of the very top of the
organization the relationship the CEO
has with the chairman and no like
stifling board in the way is such a huge
competitive advantage over time
absolutely and I think you know recently
we've had exactly that dilemma where you
know we had the opportunity to work you
know with an oem taking a significant
shareholding in the team but I think it
was recognized that hang on that that
DNA will be affected
um if we cannot continue to operate
exactly in the manner that's made us
successful with that a ability to make
quick fire decisions
without having to go through layers and
layers of you know process and
bureaucracy
quick word from one of our sponsors I've
got a tip for all of you that will make
your virtual meeting experiences I think
10 times better
as some of you may know by now Blue
Jeans by Verizon offers seamless high
quality video conferencing but the
reason why I use blue jeans versus other
video conferencing tools is because of
immersion their tools make you feel more
connected to the employees or customers
you're trying to engage with and now
they're launching one of their biggest
feature enhancements to impact virtual
events so far called Blue Jean Studio I
actually used it the other day I did a
virtual event using the studio which I
think about 700 of you came to TV level
production quality all done by one
person with very little technical
experience on a laptop so if you've got
an event coming up and you're thinking
about doing it virtually check out blue
jean studio now let me know what you
think because I genuinely believe I know
this is an advert and I'm supposed to
say this but I genuinely believe it's
the best tool I've seen for doing really
immersive simple but high quality
production virtual events
quick one for many years people have
been asking for a coffee flavored Hill
and quite recently he'll release the
iced coffee caramel flavor of their um
ready to drink Hills and I've just
become hooked on it over the last couple
of weeks I've been on a really
interesting Journey with huel which I've
described and talked about a little bit
on this podcast I started with the berry
ready to drinks then I moved over to the
protein salted caramel because it's 100
calories and it gives you all of your
essential vitamins and minerals but also
gives you the 20 odd grams of protein
you need and now I'm balanced between
them both I drink mostly the banana
flavor ready to drink I've got really
into the iced coffee caramel flavor of
Jules ready to drink and now I'm
drinking that as well as the protein
make sure you try the new ready to drink
flavors that the caramel flavor is
amazing the new banana flavor as well is
amazing and obviously as I said the iced
coffee caramel flavor has been a real
Smash Hit so check it out let me know
what you think on social media I see all
of your tags and Instagram posts and
tweets about your
the podcast
you talked about Innovation being both
at the heart of the Red Bull brand but
also
um it being a big
component of what you brought to Red
Bull to make it a winning machine how
did the Red Bull team innovate versus
other incumbents
I think we grabbed the regulation so
initially it was about building and and
making sure that we got the right tools
so from 2005 when robot came into the
sport for the first four years was about
you know recruiting Adrian getting some
other key people around him making sure
that we got the right simulation tools
and our wind tunnel was delivering
reliable results and then a big
regulation change came for the 2009
season which felt like a a clean sheet
of paper for this group to really you
know grab hold off and it was a big
regulation change at the at the time
and you know we got it we got it right
or mainly right
um because there was contention with the
governing body about something called a
double diffuser which
um certain teams had and others didn't
but it got caught up in the politics
between
the governing body and the commercial
rights hold on the teams who were all
arguing for a bigger share and we sort
of got caught in the crossfire of that
you know and it was really about Ferrari
and and the FIA and had nothing to do
with Red Bull but we come up with a
competitive car
um and then suddenly
you know we were able to start competing
and start winning
and we were making mistakes but we were
we were fast we were challenging we were
winning races and we lost out on that
championship at the end of the year to
Jensen button and and Ross Braun because
we'd had a weak start
um due to these this regulation
uh discrepancy
um but then from you know 2010 we took
that momentum into that year
and we're still a little rough around
the edges but we managed to you know
basically polish ourselves enough that
we came out with both championships at
the end of 2010 11 then we went on and
and was a totally dominant year and then
a big regulation came for 12 we had to
adopt to that and won it at the final
race in in Brazil against uh Fernando
Alonso and then stability into 2013 saw
another dominant year
um for the team and then obviously then
it was a complete reset because when
2014 came along all of the engine
regulations changed to this V6 hybrid
and we were completely out of bed the
engine that we had was nowhere near the
competitiveness of uh certainly that
Mercedes had come up with and suddenly
you go from
being serial winners to turning up at a
race and not having a chance
of success and that was that was tough
to keep
the hearts and minds of the people
um having been used to winning to
suddenly turning up and you know if
we're lucky we we won three races that
year that were all opportunistic but you
know in terms of competing for a
championship no chance how do you do
that how did you keep their hearts and
Minds motivated focused I think you you
identify again the area that's that's
causing the weakness and look to address
it and focus on the bits that you can
control so the engine we couldn't
control that was from a third party you
know supplier we could put pressure on
them we could we could try and uh assist
them with tools that we had but all we
could do is ensure that we made the best
chassis that we could possibly make that
we got the best drivers and we got the
best out of them and so
um you know races that weren't sensitive
to power
you know we could Challenge and win
those whether there's a Monaco or it was
uh you know Budapest type you know uh
circuit
um and uh then looked to address
the the weakness and it took us until
2019.
and again a big change from uh one
engine supplier to another manufacturer
to a Honda to suddenly have that ability
to you know start challenging for for
victories and start to build a
championship challenge I didn't realize
that in um in Formula One there were so
many changes with engines and
regulations so often
it's changing all the time sometimes
even in the year really you know changes
are introduced and uh
you know we've seen that we've seen that
this year
um and it's not uncommon for
clarifications or technical directives
sometimes hidden behind the grounds of
safety to be you know to be introduced
and it's about how you adapt to those
changes
and that's a culture question of culture
right it is is you know you can push
against it but a certain point you've
got to accept it and uh uh and get on
with it and and think okay how how can
we turn
you know you know [ __ ] into fertilizer
you know at the end of the day and and
and you've got to embrace you've got to
embrace the change and you've got to go
with it when I look at my competition in
all the industries that I'm competing in
professionally
I could tell you the answer to the
question why why I will win
like I have my thesis as to why me and
my team will beat them yeah
um based on it might be culture it might
be philosophy it might be we care more
about this thing and over the long term
that's going to pay off when you look at
your competition which has been Mercedes
yes for in all the press and on on the
race track over the last couple of years
why do you think your team will win
I think that there's several factors I
think that you know something
performance is always cyclical and yeah
Mercedes went through an incredible
winning spree you know longer than we
certainly did and at some point that was
always going to come to an end whether
it's through complacency or what
whatever cause is that
and I wanted to make sure that we were
the team on the upward
graft capitalize on any sign of weakness
and I think
you know there were several components
one of course is the driver the driver
played a key role you know in that in
the max verstappen you know emerging as
this exciting
determining character and you will not
meet a more determined personality or
driver with more commitment and and
passion than that the Max and the team
just having this
this inner belief and and again pushing
all of the boundaries operating at a
level that was taking ourselves out of
our comfort zone whether that be well
record-breaking pit stops aggressive
strategies attacking strategies taking
calculated risks
um to you know with high risk High
reward and uh with very much an attitude
and we've got nothing to lose you know
we've got we've got to throw everything
at this and I think it just in the end
came down to to desire that there was
more desire
um and the way that we applied ourselves
as a team under massive pressure
we dealt with that pressure
yeah you know in a in a very together
manner
how hard do you push people I know you
said you let them get on with their job
and that they know better than than you
do at what they're there to do but in
terms of those one-on-one conversations
you're having with those people
to get them to break those records in
the pit stop or to get them to really
embody the culture of Red Bull and want
to win regardless of whether they've won
last year regardless of what's been
written about in The Press what are
those conversations and how hard do you
do you have to push I think you've
always got to encourage people to get
out of their comfort zone because if
you're in your comfort zone you're
cruising you've got to push your
yourself now I'm not a table Banger or
you know a hair dryer like an Alex
Ferguson but it's about getting people
to
go that extra go that extra step to take
themselves out of their comfort zone
easiest thing in the world is not to
have any change but you've got to
continually evolve
and so whilst we've had tremendous
stability the way that the organization
has evolved is even in the last two
years is enormous as we've embraced new
challenges of taking on being an engine
manufacturer which is something
completely nuts why would an energy
drinks subsidiary take on Mercedes-Benz
and Ferrari and Renault and Honda as a
being an engine manufacturer but it's it
it takes our own destiny into our own
control and brings everything under one
one roof and becomes completely
integrated so in many respects is
totally logical
um but starting from scratch is just
about attracting again all the same
Basics that served us well on the
chassis of getting the right people the
right tools the right structure and
having a can-do attitude of yeah we're
gonna we're gonna shoot for the stars
and maybe we're gonna land on the moon
but you know we're not afraid of taking
on a challenge
have you got a complacency detector
built into your mind can you sense when
you feel like people in teams are
becoming complacent you can you can
sense it you can you can feel it you
know if I have
um
you know there's almost a guilt factor
that you feel that hang well I'm I don't
feel like I'm busy enough I need to be
busier
[Music]
um and you so you push yourself and I
think
in turn you end up you know pushing
other areas of the of the business and I
think covid was a a phenomenal challenge
um the you know I took everybody by
surprise again he said how do you take
on that challenge and you know we had
went from a culture of having probably
about five people that had the ability
to work remotely because we're paranoid
about IP and information going out of
the business overnight we went to 400 we
didn't even know where there are I.T
systems would be able to cope with it
and then had to maintain that culture
during this totally alien process of
being locked in your in your home but
and everything happening on Zoom calls
and uh and video conferencing and having
to design a car remotely
um but by keeping that essence of team
and communicating and and talking uh we
managed to keep that embody that sense
of of Teen
um and I think that was a big factor in
why we came up with such a competitive
car
in 22 or for the 2021 season because
what we've done through covid in keeping
that essence of team together
just Kate gave us a better product for
2021.
you must really obsess about the small
stuff because you know all these
different departments all these teams
all it takes is a small pocket of
complacency for the standards to drop a
couple of percent in the car
if one team doesn't communicate properly
or if they just don't you know really
push themselves to find a marginal gain
that can cause like a couple of percent
drop in the performance of the car that
can lead you a a championship
you can lose championships as we've seen
yeah in seconds yeah yeah yeah after
years of work just a few seconds but I
think what we've managed to develop
within the business now is this this uh
again culture of not wanting to let the
site down not wanting to be the link in
the chain that that that breaks and uh
you know whether that's from
you know van drivers hitting deliveries
of you know to to suppliers to
machinists or designers or uh
technicians at the circuit or or
mechanics or Engineers
um that runs the whole way through the
business that nobody wants to let the
side down and I think that uh
everybody's got that vested interest in
seeing those cars
you know succeed and when they do the
sense of Pride and fulfillment and of
course you have to celebrate success
have to enjoy success because it's not
going to happen every single day you're
going to lose a lot more races than
you're going to win so when you win
embrace it enjoy it celebrate that
moment which is what we do as a team
after every single race if we win a race
we get everybody together with a
champagne after the race in the race
Bays on a Monday uh you know afternoon
to celebrate that success and if we
haven't won you know we'll talk about
okay why didn't we win what do we need
to do better even when we won and we've
celebrated we're saying okay how can we
still be better how can we improve you
know on this and and getting everybody
to share that moment to share in that
success is something that's so so
important
uh because then everybody collectively
feels it after you won the title in 2021
how did it feel
2021 for me personally was
hugely challenging year because
there was the pressure of everything
going on track
[Music]
um
there was an awful lot going on off
track as well as we're building this
engine business and
so you're recruiting from you know rival
teams and because Mercedes being UK
based there was a lot of people coming
out of Mercedes that heightened the
pressure there was then a big PR
uh battle as well so you're in front of
the cameras every week you're having to
defend your position or defend your
driver and and it was very concerted in
in all directions you could feel the
pressure and building and building it
was like a heavyweight bout from round
one in Bahrain through 22 rounds so when
we got it to Abu Dhabi and
we went into Abu Dhabi equal on points
with Max being a head virtue of
um uh race victories Mercedes had gone
there with the barristers because they
were convinced that Max was just going
to drive into
um Lewis I think on the first lap and uh
they'd be arguing it out uh in the in in
the stewards but you know we qualified
on on pole and then for the majority of
that race
um we felt that decisions went against
us at the beginning of the race because
Max have made a pass and Lewis had cut
the chicane but he wasn't told to give
the position back and everything we
tried in that race
it felt like it was slipping away and so
what was going through my mind was like
how am I going to pick the guys up you
know after what am I going to say to Max
hat you know after such an intense
season like this
um you know what am I gonna gonna say to
them and then suddenly it just shows
that
you know anything can happen in life and
suddenly yeah a window of opportunity
presented itself with
um one of the back markers crashing
uh and you know we had to be on our feet
we took the risk we made the pit stop we
bolted on a new set of tires and
Mercedes went defensive and conservative
and that gave us a window of opportunity
to challenge for One racing lap
um and with a fresh set of tires and Max
verstappen in your car
he was going to go for it and so when he
pulled the move off at a corner that we
completely unexpected I think Lewis
totally unexpected it because he left
the door open there trying to get a good
exit onto the onto the straight
it was like oh my God and then you know
they're going down the street they're
side by side and you know they get to
the chicane and it's
he went in a little bit deep and you
know the strength of Mercedes engine on
the straight line you've got to get the
exit onto the next straight and then
they're side by side
and then he managed to keep and protect
the the inside line into the next left
hand and you know at that point it's
Dunbar it's you know something breaking
on the car
and then the feeling of of just
everything being lifted
and to see him after seven long years of
we've been nowhere we hadn't even been
able to challenge them and then suddenly
to see everything culminate in seeing
your driver and car and team cross the
Checker that flag to become the world
champion that that was that was just it
was very emotional and you just felt all
this pressure suddenly lift from you
was that the greatest professional
moment of your career today undoubtedly
I mean the first time I won it uh you
know I was 35 or something like that and
that was in the last race in Abu Dhabi
against the odds with Sebastian Vettel
so that was a unique feeling and it was
one of the rare races that Dietrich
Massachusetts would uh that actually
came to so for him to be there was very
special and
um that you know that was a massive
moment for the whole for the whole
company for the whole business
uh but I think having been through the
tough times
during that period of not just
domination Annihilation by one of your
opponents
um to never lose sight of what the end
goal was and to fulfill that and to win
it on the last lap I mean you you
couldn't have written it nobody would
have believed it if somebody came up
with a script and said that's the way
this season's gonna pan out nobody would
have uh you know believed it
um so for sure it was
you know probably the the biggest moment
of my career so far and the whole world
was watching I think if people weren't
into the F1 someone sent them a text and
told them to turn the TV on at that
point I remember that certainly what
happened with me I remember getting many
messages and in some of our Sports chats
and WhatsApp going oh my God oh my God
oh see turn on the TV and you're
watching this last lap and it's just
the most crazy it was insane and and of
course like yeah you know it was one of
the most I think it was the most singly
viewed piece of sport
um certainly last year if not in the
last five years and there'll probably
never be a Formula One Championship like
it in the next 20 years
um it was so epic and of course sport is
polarizing so you know on the one hand
you've got
you know the verstappen fans going
bananas thinking it was retribution for
what had happened earlier in the year
you've got the the Hamilton fans
thinking that you know the races have
been interfered with and it was unfair
um and then you've got the neutrals that
are just witnessed the most phenomenal
race between two magnificent drivers and
teams operating at the at the top of
their game and so for the sport
he you know it was it was fantastic
because suddenly again we're just
engaging with a whole new audience
and wherever we go in the world now you
know formula one is
having its moment in the spotlight it is
you know you know it is sold out and the
demand for formula one is just huge
wherever we go find a button on the desk
now and the button was a eraser button
and it would erase Mercedes as a team it
just to raise the whole team would you
press it no because it's enjoyable
you know racing against a team of their
quality because I mean they raise the
stakes and they raised the bar and then
we had to raise it higher to beat them
and so the uh the satisfaction that that
gives you
um is immense and I think what
you know what we're really proud of this
year is that we put everything into last
year
even at the expense of this year because
again another massive regulation change
coming into this year the biggest in the
last 40 years without consoled ourselves
to say look we'll put more time into
2021 and if that costs us a slower start
to 22
we'll take that if we can come away with
a trophy
um we managed to Come Away with the
trophy but we also managed to start the
season with a competitive car compared
to all of the other teams that it's you
know we're sure the last team swap over
onto the 22 car but such was the
determination and and the motivation
within the within the business
uh and the talent the car that's been
delivered for the drivers this year has
been again phenomenal where does your
motivation come from You've Won You've
Won You've Won you've gone through a
period of you know a battle with
Mercedes you've won again what is
driving you now
for me
[Music]
um
you know there's no better feeling than
winning and when you've won you want to
win it again and you want to win it
again but for me the next challenge as
well is really the next chapter
for the company where not only is a
chassis manufacturer but as an engine
manufacturer taking a business from
scratch bill that we built a factory in
55 weeks we designed and fired up an
engine within 12 months these are
ridiculous time scales that we're
operating to but again it just
typifies the the can-do culture that you
know that there is within the business
and so for sure the next challenge for
us is as a as a as an engine and power
unit manufacturer to take on some of
these iconic Brands
um you know come 2026 when a Red Bull
car pulls out of the garage with a
ripple engine powering it going up
against the Ferraris and Mercedes and
Audis at the time and and so it's going
to be phenomenal naivety you became a
principal at a very young age yeah
a lot of incumbents were double your age
a lot of you know the it was quite a an
older business with Legacy systems and
ways of doing things
people often view naivety and youth as a
disadvantage how was it how was your
naivety an advantage to you in hindsight
I turned it to an advantage because I
think people underestimate youth
um and for me age was never a barrier it
was it was just a number and it's how
you apply yourself so when I came into
the sport I was the youngest
team principle in Formula One I still am
to this day ironically really yeah after
18 years wow
um but you know there were guys that had
been in sport icons of the sport you
know whether it was a Bernie eccleston's
or Ron Dennis or Flavio bread Torres or
jean-toed running Ferrari and you know
even Eddie Jordan was still around with
with Jordan uh Grand Prix at the time
and all you know very entrepreneurial
people but all very different but very
single-minded and again it's how you you
conduct yourself and
um I didn't go into you know into that
Forum banging tables or anything like
that I I looked I listened and I I would
say something when I thought I had
something to say
um and and you learn as well you know
you learn from a way that
you know Ron Dennis conducts himself
versus a Flavia britory versus a Frank
Williams or you know Bernie Eccleston uh
again is a complete ring Master how he
operated the business was you know was a
phenomenal education
you know for me and what you saw in each
one of those people
it just presented itself in a very
different way way was this ruthless
competitiveness
when you have a ruthless competitiveness
you're obsessed you want to win you're
traveling six months a year to compete
and to win
you're consumed in these external
battles with the media and on the track
and off the track and with this team and
Mercedes and whatever else how would you
then be a husband and a father do you
know that is the one thing that keeps
you grounded
um and you know I'm very fortunate I've
got a really uh supportive wife
um who's obviously experienced high
pressure situations herself of having to
deliver and knowing what the scrutiny of
uh Jerry Halliwell you know
um media operated world is like so so
she you know she's been tremendously
um you know supportive
um and you know I have a you know three
children
um and they're they're what keep you
grounded
um you know they don't care what you do
as a job at the end of the day you know
my
um
eight-year-old daughter is obsessed with
horses at the moment my five-year-old
boy is just wanting to uh you know make
Lego and F-16 fighter planes
um and uh you know my 16 year old
daughter suddenly she now understands
what I do and I've actually in her eyes
almost become cool
um so but you know Fam Family is what
keeps you keeps you grounded and it
keeps you Formula One is a very
glamorous World from the outside looking
in it can be a lonely place at times
um but the end of the day we're not
saving lives
um you know it's an entertainment it's a
sport and what really matters you know
is family at the end of the day and uh
and that I think makes it more precious
in that you don't take it for granted so
the time that I do get with the family I
think it's very important to be present
and and you know not to take it for
Advantage so uh you know I'll make sure
that that I take you know the little one
to to school or pick my daughter up from
school on a uh on a Friday because I
want to be there I don't want to be an
absent uh father because I'll never get
that time
time back so and that then is being
disciplined with the management of your
own time because otherwise you know your
phones you know always next to you it
can take you know formula one can take
over your life if you're not disciplined
in in uh in your own approach
are you content
am I content I am very content in so
many ways but I'm still extremely hungry
um
and you know when is enough enough it
doesn't feel like it's enough at the
moment
and uh I think that drives
yeah you know some people
are happy to cruise others want to keep
want to keep pushing and and uh you know
I'm I feel like I've only just got going
do you ever think you will it will ever
be enough
ah
who know the problem
you know that you that certainly happens
in in this industry and I guess is the
same in in others is that time moves so
quickly you never get five minutes to
reflect and look back you're always
looking forward you know this
Championship the chapter will close
we'll enjoy it for you know a couple of
evenings and then it's all about the
next one and so you never get time to
reflect so actually sitting here talking
about something in the past actually you
start to think to think back and I think
it's it's only when you get to the end
of the journey
that then you know then uh you get times
reflected I think
when I get to the end of my journey I
will go away and do something completely
different I'll be a sheep farmer or
something like that but uh
um
yeah I think uh but I don't see that in
in sight at the moment could you ever
imagine that being an end to your
journey is that something you can
foresee now could you imagine getting to
the day where you think you know what
pina coladas for me you know I I
go to work
[Music]
um
and every day I enjoy what I do
um I I'm grateful that I've paid to do a
job that actually I'd do it for free
because you know you enjoy it you love
it I enjoy working with the people I
enjoy the sport I enjoy the competition
uh I'd probably be completely
unemployable in another uh form of of
life and I think if you've got a passion
for something that you do you do it that
much better
um and yeah money at the end of the day
is
is just a valuation of success
um it shouldn't be the reason that you
go to work
um and uh for me
um
uh you know while I have that drive
while I have that enjoyment on the bad
days as well as the as well as the good
days that's what you know motivates me
and I think maybe they'll become a day
one day that you know I've had enough
that I I can't see or envisage that have
you ever been anxious eat all that press
scrutiny
all the pressure you described have you
ever had moments of anxiety
about 10 years ago uh when we were in
the height of a
Championship battle
um
back in 2012.
I can't remember
uh feeling that that
uh you know my breathing you know I
became self-conscious of my own
breathing and then when you start
thinking about your breathing
uh you know you you you start
overthinking things and and for me as an
honest I think what what is going on you
know have I had too much coffee did I
have a rebel or too many Red Bulls you
know this morning or whatever and I
couldn't identify
you know what it was
um and uh it was only
um uh you know when I spoke to the the
team physio I said look I'm just
conscious of my breathing and it's made
me feel a bit dizzy and I think I've had
too much coffee and this that and the
other he said well
he's probably a bit of anxiety you know
and
and so I'd never you know I thought that
was a form of of weakness
um and and then I read about it and I
spoke to a couple of people about it and
you know you then learn to control your
you know your breathing and and and so
on and uh
and and I could then recognize if I felt
during that period
this feeling start to come on you know
just to to to to to you know to breathe
normally to not take short breaths but
it was to be taking you know deep
breaths and and so on and it sort of
crept up on me without
you know recognizing it and uh yeah he's
not so it's not it's not a weakness it's
just your body telling you that
you know there's a lot going on here
um and it's it's its way of protesting
um and that's what what was happening to
me at uh at that time and I recognized
it and managed to
you know to to address it and
um there's so many ways whether it's
meditation or just exercise or or as I
say breathing that uh
um and and and yeah I was able to then
if ever I got those symptoms I was able
to to recognize it and say okay hello I
Know Who You Are
you know I can deal with you did you
ever seek out therapy did you ever go
get a therapist I didn't I mean my wife
is pretty together with all these things
and
um she she'd experienced the same thing
whether it was
before a show or or you know some of the
stuff they did was insane crazy and
um and so you know she she helped me uh
you know with it
um and you know to him yeah it's an
embrace it to recognize it to sort out
your breathing I tried meditating I I'm
sorry I got I couldn't even you know
um and I admire her she has a discipline
to do that every you know every day uh I
just haven't got my mind is too active
um but uh you know just definitely
um learning to to deal with it and and
it part you know it passed it was it was
with me for a couple of months and and
it passed and I think it was just my
body saying okay
stress overload here you know give me a
break that's what everyone's body seems
to do Gary Neville said to me when he
was sat here that he'd be going at such
a pace for so long that one day after
reporting on I think it was the Arsenal
game he's in the commentary box he just
collapses yeah goes to the doctors the
doctor says listen Gary you're going too
fast and you've been doing it for too
long you need to slow down yeah he
hasn't yeah but it's funny how the body
will tell you before you admit it to
yourself 100 100
my last question to you before I just
ask you this one in the book is on a
personal level what are you working on I
understand your professional Ambitions
it's very clear but on a personal level
when you think about what you want to
improve about yourself with your in your
personal situation what is what is that
I think it's
trying to be
um
you know the best father that you can be
the best husband that you can be
um I think that
you know we're all aware of our own
mortality particularly with events like
you know who thought the queen was kind
of you know gonna die with that and
again and that just brings it all home
to you that you know we're we're on this
planet for such a short period of time
to
you know do as much as you can with the
time that we that we have here and to uh
ensure that you make time
um because we're all you know
specifically informal line you're
chasing time all the time life is
dictated by the by the stopwatch but
it's important to make time
um to be able to have
you know that's that that uh incredibly
important family time
um and uh and yeah just to be able to to
to chill out uh which sometimes is
difficult to be able to relax is
sometimes a tough thing to do especially
if you're working at a you know on a
high Tempo but um
uh you know as in work you can always
you can always be better you can always
do better Eddie hunt said that to me
obviously his book is I know you've
spoken to him but his book is called
Relentless so yeah yeah here's someone
that I don't think is willing to relax
uh at any cost and I hear that quite
often we have a tradition here where the
last guest asks a question for the next
guest they don't know who they're
writing it for right and the question
that's been written for you is quite an
interesting one I don't get to see until
I open this book but the question that's
been written for you
is
this can be taken in many ways okay how
will you control your own greed
how will I control my own greed
um
I think greed is
greed and jealousy are two very
destructive
components
um and I think
I've never been a greedy person but I
think you're greedy for titles greedy
for titles
um in that respect but I think
if
you need to be magnanimous as well and I
think that if you're fortunate enough to
um
you know achieve success
the most gratifying thing to be able to
do is
to do something good with it to empower
something either whether it be through
charity work or or just making a
difference making a difference for for
good because it's not just about the
trophies and the uh and the plot it it's
sometimes about doing something good as
well do you spend enough time thinking
about that
um I don't I'm gonna I'm gonna admit I
can always do more yeah you can always
do more yeah and when you do something
good and and that
can be more rewarding than winning a
race than that the feeling that gives
you think actually I should actually do
do more there's almost a bit of a bias
with the mind when you when you feel
like you're constantly running to keep
things moving and throwing coal in the
engine that you think I'll do that thing
when I'll be the philanthropist when
yeah and I remember one day sitting here
with someone who said the correct
approach Steve is to make sure you're
you don't cut down the forest and then
donate to the bees you're learning to do
both at the same time effectively
absolutely
thank you so much for your time
um incredibly inspiring individual
that's reached the very peak of their
powers and there's very few people I can
speak to in this country and in the
world that have managed to stay at the
top of their game Championship off the
championship whether they win or whether
they don't win and that reinvention and
what sits behind that in terms of team
and culture and philosophy and
optimism and attitude are so fascinating
to me because
winning is one thing but continuing to
win with new people as the world is
changing as regulations are changing
around you is a completely different
task especially in such a technical
industry like yours where there's so
many components that you have to leave
to trust so it's so inspiring to read
your story
um and it's so wonderful to see F1
becoming more and more popular in
culture because there's so much about it
that um I think we teaches us lessons
about life and teamwork and all of these
really important fundamentals
um and yeah it's it's an honor to meet
you as well because from an
entrepreneurial business standpoint
you're an inspiration to me for so many
reasons so thank you for the
conversation today thank you for being
so honest and open and I appreciate your
time no thank you very much I've enjoyed
it
quick one as you might know crafted are
one of the sponsors of this podcast and
they make really meaningful pieces of
jewelry this lion piece they've made I
wear all the time along with the little
timepiece the sand timer that I wear
often and the lion piece you might have
seen Conor McGregor has a similar piece
which was custom made for him for me it
represents courage and if you walk
through my house the house that I'm in
right now if you walk six feet in that
direction you'll see a huge lion
portrait if you go upstairs you'll see a
lion portrait if you look behind me on
the Shelf near the top there you'll see
a line as well the reason my house and
my life is surrounded by lions is
because they represent courage calmness
and that tenacity that I've applied to
my business success to my professional
life into everything in between for me
the line has always been an animal that
can be almost a bit of a contradiction
they are so loving and so caring of
their own and can be powerful and
courageous when necessary in order to
achieve what they want to achieve so if
you like me are a big fan of Courage
bravery ambition while also being calm
and composed check out this line piece
and let me know if you get it
foreign
[Music]